this video is brought to you by morning
brew
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
since the inception of mainstream
computers intel has been instrumental in
powering the industry
they were the first company to invent
the cpu which is the brain of all
computers
and for decades their chips dominated
the market
in the 1950s and 60s before intel's
groundbreaking chip
circuit chips were needed for each
application a computer performed
in contrast a cpu is a single chip that
could be programmed to run anything
the impact of the invention of the cpu
can't be understated
and to this day the technology remains
intel's main product
but recently intel's performance lead
has all but been eaten away
by amd and they're also being challenged
by apple as we saw in a recent episode
to make things worse they've lost the
crown of america's most valuable chip
manufacturer
to nvidia a company known for their
graphics chips and more recently
ai research in this two-part series
we'll take a look at how intel was
founded and how they came to dominate
the industry
and then in the next episode we'll look
at how they manage to get into trouble
and what lies ahead in the future let's
begin
you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
first developed in 1947 by john bardeen
and walter brettain and under the
supervision of william shockley the
transistor
is perhaps the most revolutionary
invention of the 20th century
the original purpose of the device was
simply to amplify
that is strengthen electrical signals
but it soon turned into something much
greater
no one could have expected the
revolution that something so physically
small
would bring to business culture and
society
today our computers have billions of
transistors tucked away in their chips
and it's what makes them tick
so how does it work in addition to
amplifying signals
a transistor at its fundamental level
can essentially behave as a switch
they can control the flow of electrons
by being either in an on state
or an off state these on off states can
be translated into binary code
a one or a zero which is how all of our
data currently exists
by switching between states billions of
times a second
these little transistors allow data to
be processed and manipulated
giving us the digital world of today
even in the late 1940s transistors held
a lot of promise
if enough of them could be packed into a
sufficiently small space
there was potential for some serious
computing power
this is what intel would eventually do
but for the time being there was still a
major
problem the problem was that these
transistors had to be connected by wires
these connections could only be so tiny
before the system becomes unreliable
the dream for scientists was to condense
a whole circuit
the transistors the wires and everything
they needed
into a single step a printed circuit
board
if they could create a miniature circuit
in one piece all the parts could be much
smaller
and also mass-produced the answer
was the integrated circuit the idea was
to use a chemical etching process
to create the transistor connections
instead of wires
the next step enables us to interconnect
the various components
and to make contact with them but
instead of another diffusion
a layer of metal is deposited over the
entire surface of the wafer
then by using the proper masks the
excess metal can be etched away
the group that came up with the
breakthrough of the integrated circuit
was also headed by william shockley the
same man in charge of the transistor
team
as novel as this idea was the technology
was impractical at the time
more on this later
william shockley was not the most
pleasant team leader
and he had a bad reputation these
conflicts that his personality had with
others
caused him to leave the east coast of
the us and travel west to start afresh
his latest endeavor would be humbly
named shockley semiconductor lab
despite his personality flaws he had an
eye for talent
and managed to recruit eight of the
greatest engineers and scientists the
united states had to offer
some of these recruits in shockley's lab
would go on to create intel
but before doing so they would first
create the most
significant company in technology
history a company forgotten by most
today
the way this came to be was an
interesting story within itself
eight members of shockley's
semiconductor lab just grew tired of his
erratic and paranoid nature
in fact some of you that have read my
book will know that william shockley got
jealous of his team's discovery of the
transistor and wanted to receive
all the credit despite not being
directly involved in it
these eight dissenting members of
shockley's lab were
sheldon roberts eugene kleiner victor
greenwich
j last julius blanc robert noyce
gordon moore and jean hoenrei they would
be given the nickname
the traitorous eight one day
in a san francisco hotel the group
gathered together
recognizing all of their talents and
despising william shockley
they hatched a plan together they all
pledged to sign a dollar bill
this represented their commitment to
starting a new company
this meeting at the san francisco hotel
would be later called
one of the top 10 days that changed
history by the new york times
the plan was to start a new company that
was to be under the reluctant leadership
of robert noyce
a brilliant mit researcher at first
noyce was hesitant to take on such an
ambitious project
as he had a young family startups like
this were a huge risk in the 1950s
but after some convincing noyce bit the
bullet and signed the dollar bill
and with that the traitorous 8 had a new
spin-off company
and its name was fairchild semiconductor
fairchild semiconductor was in essence
the origins of silicon valley
i personally find it amazing at how
influential this company was
fairchild semiconductor started silicon
valley in both technology and culture
the culture was like a college dormitory
for competitive geniuses
and staff were making big money
competing with each other
soon fairchild was on a meteoric rise
the company operated differently to
anything that had been seen before
risk over stability innovation over
tradition
rapid experimentation over slow and
steady growth
there was a lot of buzz in the media
about this new and exciting company
they were like the amazon apple or
google of their day
in both the stock market and technology
space
out of this company's talent came of
course intel
but also lsi logic sandisk
and advanced micro machines otherwise
known as
amd the latter would play a big role in
the second part of the story
it's interesting to note that by the
1980s
100 different companies had sprung from
the talent pool of fairchild
after securing financial backing the
group at fairchild would come together
to produce the first
practical integrated circuit by using a
silicon semiconductor
the invention for the first time made it
practically
possible to tightly pack transistors
together but also
allow them to function independently
despite being made from a single piece
steve jobs in 2005 would say that
silicon valley is a bit like running a
relay race
and fairchild semiconductors were the
ones that passed the baton to him
to bring in the era of personal
computing to this day
fairchild remains important in samsung's
supply chain
so fairchild semiconductor had invented
the practical integrated circuit
and birthed silicon valley culture they
were flying high
and well ahead of established tech
titans like ibm and motorola
but as time went on staff began to leave
fairchild in pursuit of other endeavors
companies like texas instruments and
motorola started catching up
robert noyce realized that he needed to
start something new
in 1968 he and his fellow employee
gordon moore
began a new project to make memory chip
devices these were to compete with
magnetic hard drives
noise and more status in the industry
coupled with the rise of venture
capitalists
resulted in 2.5 million dollars being
raised in under two days for their new
project
the pair of them picked the best and
brightest minds to join the new company
among these was andy grove a
hungarian-born chemical engineer
that joined fairchild's r d division in
his role was director of operations
former employees would state
that hiring andy was the best decision
noes ever made
he was a driven man who wanted
everything to be well done
and done on time neither noise nor more
were stern enough to crack the whip
together they called their new company
intel
an abbreviation of integrated
electronics which also happened to
conjure the word intelligence
it didn't garner a lot of attention from
the media at the time but within silicon
valley there was a great deal of
excitement
as intel engineers continued to tinker
with the design of their memory chip
they decided that they should take on
some custom work to make some revenue to
further build up the business
in the spring of 1969 a simple request
came into the intel building altering
the course of computer history
in 1969 a japanese firm busycom
contracted intel to design 12
specialized microchips for its new
calculator
unfortunately what busycom wanted was
going to be way too complicated and
expensive for intel to produce
a young engineer named ted hoff was in
charge of designing the architecture and
he raised his concerns
he thought intel had bitten off more
than they could chew
when hoff voiced his concerns to robert
noyce noyce replied
if you can think of a simpler design you
should pursue it
noyce always encouraged the people in
this lab to run with their ideas and see
where they went
this next part was the genius of a true
inventor you see
ted hoff envisioned a single chip that
could be programmed for a specific
application
in this instance it would function like
a calculator but it could be programmed
to do anything
the normal thing to do in the 1960s was
to build custom circuit chip boards
for each application in this new
architecture of hofs
the memory calculating processing
functions and other aspects of a
computer
could be combined into one integrated
circuit in this case the 12 chips could
just be one
a unit which could run all programs on
its own a system
called a cpu when the design of this new
type of architecture was done
they needed someone who could put it all
into silicon thus
another talented chip designer federico
fagin
was brought in to oversee the
implementation
he arrived at intel in april of 1970 and
brought his own experience to bear on
the project
federico fagin was also from fairchild
and he had invented
silicon gate technology a fundamental
building block for the microprocessor
fairchild wasn't taking advantage of his
invention and he wanted to use his new
technology to design advanced chips
he was brought to intel six months late
for the project because the company was
running behind
the very next day after he was hired
japanese management from busycom
was due to visit and it didn't go well
when the day that i joined intel stein
mazer
showed me a block diagram that was to be
the
busycom project so shima arrived he said
where
i'm here to check where is logic and i
said uh oh
i gave him the what i was given you know
this block diagram and this stuff
and he said no good this is i had this
this only idea i want logic and i said i
don't have any logic
you bad you bad
i said i just arrived here i just i just
was hired yesterday
you late
and so i was i was buffal
and of course at that point there were a
number of very agitated phone calls
and i could tell by the tone of the
conversation but they were not
very gentle phone calls and uh
and basically in the meantime i tried
very hard
to figure out a time schedule that would
really minimize the delay that was
incurred by intel
but to do that i needed an engineer to
help me and also adequate layout and
technician support
i was by myself i had no engineers no
layout people
that's it i had to do it by myself
federico
basically had to do everything himself
and just figure it out
despite the odds in february of the
following year working kits were
delivered to the clients
and in november of that year the intel
made its debut on the market and the
error of the cpu microprocessor had
begun
the whole team's efforts had led to the
world's first cpu
essentially a whole general purpose
computer on a chip
ted hof convinced management that they
should sell this general purpose chip as
a standalone product
the result was the intel 4004 cpu
it had more than 2 000 transistors and
the device was advertised as a
quote computer on a chip
at 3.2 by 4.2 millimeters the chip that
the intel team had unveiled had as much
power as one of the first electronic
computers the eniac of the 1940s used 18
000 vacuum tubes and was so large it
filled an entire room
though computers had gotten smaller
since those days what intel had done was
still a giant leap above what was
available at the time
the intel 4004 chip took a current day
1969 computer that was the size of a
refrigerator
and shrunk it down to fit onto a
fingertip
to give even more perspective the ibm
cost 2 500 a month to rent and had the
same performance as the intel 4004
chip which cost just 60 dollars
in this moment the digital revolution
had officially begun
[Music]
amazingly some still had reservations
when the 4004 cpu was unveiled people
couldn't believe it
ted hoff would recall one such
interaction at a computing conference in
las vegas 1971.
quote one customer who came in was
adamant that we had such
nerve to claim that we had a computer on
a chip one of our engineers handed him
the data sheet
and he looked at it and exclaimed oh my
god
it really is a computer it was something
that people did not believe was possible
at the time
[Music]
it's also important to note that
personal computers didn't exist
it was assumed that there will be no
consumer market for it
ken oslon chairman of digital equipment
corporation
famously remarked in the sunday times
quote there is no reason
anyone would want a computer in their
home obviously
this was wrong a slightly later version
of the chip
the intel 8080 would be at the heart of
the first
widespread personal computer it was in
the form of a kit
built by the company mit this
intel-powered computer
was the very same that was on the front
of a magazine that bill gates was shown
kicking off microsoft and the very same
computer that some californian hippies
would show off to their friends at the
homebrew computer club
kicking off apple computer
before we continue let's check out a
quick news report from our sponsor
morningbrew
intel's industry competitiveness has
been so poor that it was announced last
wednesday that its ceo
bob swann will be stepping down as of
the 15th of february
he'll be replaced by vmware's ceo pat
gelsinger
the news for intel comes after more chip
delays competition from amd
samsung and also apple breaking ties
with them after 15 years
intel has been accused of quote failed
leadership by investors
if you're short on time and want to get
all of the news in business and
technology
morning brew is a great way to do that
morning brew makes the latest news fun
and easy
you can get up to date with all the
latest breaking news in just five
minutes
all in one place without having to
trundle through different news sources
it's delivered to your email inbox each
weekday and saturday
click the link below to subscribe to
morning brew today it takes just 15
seconds to sign up
intel would go on to be a massive player
in the 1980s but surprisingly
they weren't the leader by 1985 their
sales were slipping and they were
suffering huge losses and expensive
development costs
by this time motorola had caught up and
was making the best performing chips at
the time
the motorola 68000 chip proved popular
and was being used in graphical
computers like the mac
commodore amiga and atari st it would
take the intel 386 to change all of that
the 386 processors from intel
transformed the industry
in the mid-80s the chip manufacturing
industry convention was that when a
computer vendor purchased cpus
they would require a second source for
the chip a legacy business move from
military contractors who needed a
reliable supply
in effect for intel or anyone to sell
their chips
they would agree to enable a competitor
to license their technology
so surprisingly in the very early days
intel
actually helped set up other companies
like amd and fujitsu as secondary
sources for compatible chips
in fact amd began life as a secondary
source supplier for companies
using intel technology this all changed
with intel's 386
it was a very very risky move for the
company it took four years of
development and cost 100 million dollars
but intel decided not to license the
technology to competitors
ibm intel's biggest client at the time
wasn't interested in the 386 for this
reason
but compaq decided to go all in and
became the first computer company to use
the new processor
the early success of the compact 386 pc
played an important role in legitimizing
the pc clone industry and de-emphasizing
ibm's role within it
by this point ibm never again had a
leadership position in pcs
and for intel the rest was history
by 1992 intel had 83 percent of the cpu
market
and more than one billion dollars in
annual profit
in 1993 intel would unveil the pentium
one
at a speed of 60 megahertz it was a
decent performer
this was followed by the pentium pro in
1995 the pentium 2
in 1997. pentium 3 in 1999
and pentium 4 in 2000 each generation
was faster than the previous
with ever smaller but more numerous
transistors
these chips were insanely popular and
thanks to some heavy marketing
the name pentium became synonymous with
pcs in the 90s and early 2000s
for intel it seemed like having their
manufacturing and chip design
all in the one place was really paying
off but this vertical integration would
later come back to give them grave
problems
there was a brief challenge to intel by
amd in the late 90s
but by 2012 amd had lost 1 billion in
that year alone and they had a net loss
of 7 billion
in the past 15 years previous
it would take a new ceo by the name of
lisa to start turning it all around in
2014.
an mit graduate and semiconductor
industry veteran
she had to make some bold bets to unseat
intel and some of these bets
wouldn't begin to pay off for another
five years but for now
intel was still the undisputed king
today the microprocessor market is a
multi-billion dollar industry
intel is still currently the largest cpu
manufacturer on the planet
and despite falling behind technically
in the last few years
the impact that they've had in the
computing industry is undeniable
from a group of eight rebels who decided
to revolt against their leader in the
1960s and start one of the greatest
technology companies ever known
to a few of those members starting intel
and deciding to think differently when
it came to building chips for a japanese
client
to eventually end up changing the world
and impacting all of our lives
it's a fascinating story when you think
about it
as for ted hoff he would leave intel in
the early 1980s to accept a position
with atari as vice president of
technology
robert noyce would leave intel in the
late 70s gordon moore would theorize
moore's law
which still holds true today at 92 years
old he currently enjoys fishing
federico fagen currently leads
philanthropic efforts
to promote the study of physics
pussycom would suffer financial trouble
and go out of business in 1974.
in the next installment of this series
we'll see how intel got complacent
missed the boat on mobile processing and
is now under threat by amd
and apple as we round out the episode
i'd like to thank you for watching a
large part of this episode was based on
a little bit of my book new thinking
i'll leave a link for it in the
description below it's a fascinating
read on the last 100 years of technology
and how it all links together if you did
enjoy today's story
be sure to subscribe to cold fusion i
don't have a large budget or a team like
many channels here on youtube
it's just me and an editor that helps
out from time to time
anyway my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
next time we'll take a look at toyota's
new solid state battery that's to be
revealed later this year
until then cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking
you